good morning good afternoon or good
evening my name is Jim Freeman I'm
senior director for Global SC
development at Siemens Healthcare
Diagnostics I'm responsible for
immunoassays developed and marketed on
the Advia Centaur
family of systems
if you have questions please write them
down in the Q a box located on your
screen and at the end of the
presentation I'll be happy to answer a
few questions get a Time
for many years now you've seen media
reports concerning the sunshine vitamin
or vitamin D with this news comes a
broad spectrum of clinical and
analytical factors that can impact
vitamin D results
probably running vitamin D assays or
testing patients with a vitamin D
deficiency or insufficiency and you'd
like to know more about treatment or
you're doing research
So today we're going to talk about
vitamin D deficiency and at-risk groups
reference ranges for vitamin D results
the variability and the results between
aminoassays caused by vitamin D binding
protein and the releasing of vitamin D
from The Binding protein
we'll talk a little bit about the three
epimer of vitamin D3
we'll talk about the importance of a
total vitamin D measurement
the standardization of vitamin D test
results
which will lead into the vitamin D
standardization program or vdsp and what
that's all about
and also finally the standardization of
the Siemens assay for total vitamin D
insufficiency and efficiency rates have
increased and as a result there's an
increased concern that our global
population does not have adequate
circulating levels of vitamin D
this is due both to increase knowledge
concerning the optimum levels what they
are and the lifestyle changes that have
affected endogenous vitamin D production
where Society is moved from work and
activities outdoors to jobs and
activities that are predominantly
indoors
excuse me a second
seasonal geographical latitude time and
day time of the day cloud cover smog
skin melanin content and sunscreen or
other factors that affect the UVB
radiation exposure and vitamin D
synthesis
while sunscreen has reduced the
incidence of skin cancer it's also
reduced the vitamin D production by
about 95 percent
the decreased effective exposure to
sunlight is the most important reason
for a marked increase in vitamin D
deficiency
we also do not get enough vitamin D in
our diets milk is fortified with vitamin
D however the amount of it
that we drink has decreased since the
1960s other foods that are high in
vitamin D are fish especially salmon
mackerel and tuna
mushrooms also have a very high vitamin
D content so dietary sources though are
not enough to offset the lack of direct
sunlight
there are several high risk groups
for vitamin D deficiency
those include
infants
mother's milk contains approximately 25
IUS per liter but often the mother is
deficient in vitamin D as well therefore
infants are prescribed 400 IUS
of vitamin D daily
older adults
have reduced seven deoxy cortisol so
they cannot synthesize vitamin D as well
as as younger adults also their kidneys
are less able to produce the active
hormone 125 dihydroxy vitamin D
obese individuals are at risk for
vitamin D deficiency due to the fact
that vitamin D is solubilized in fat and
is therefore not able to be transported
through the through the body
and also dark-skinned individuals are at
risk for vitamin D deficiency due to
melanin content and darker skin people
which
absorbs the sunlight therefore not
allowing the UVB to be absorbed
there we are so there's considerable
discussion of serum concentrations of 25
hydroxy vitamin D associated with
deficiency and sufficiency for normal
bone health as well as Optimum overall
health for individuals
so as you can see here the deficiency is
defined as less than 20 nanograms per ml
insufficiency is 20 to 30 nanograms per
ML and sufficiency is greater than 30
nanograms per mL of total vitamin D
although the Institute of medicine
report provides guidance proprietary
dietary standards for the general public
which will be used by government
agencies to set dietary regulations the
endocrine Society recommendations are
intended for use by clinicians with
patients who are who are at risk for
deficiency
so you'll see here that the Institute of
medicine and the endocrine Society do
have different cutoffs depending upon
the application for which they're
determined
there are two major forms of vitamin D
there's vitamin D2 which is synthesized
by plants and not produced by the human
body
and that is vitamin D3
which is made in large quantities when
sunlight strikes the bare skin
it can also be ingested from animal
sources
season seasonal changes geographical
latitude time of day and cloud cover
and the use of sunscreen are among the
factors that affect the UVB radiation
exposure and vitamin D synthesis
the sunlight from November to February
above the 42 degrees of latitude
produces insufficient levels of UVB for
successful
synthesis of 25 hydroxy vitamin D
UVB radiation
penetrates unprotected skin and converts
cutaneous seven
hydroxycortisol to pre-vitamin D3 which
then isomerizes to vitamin D3
the other source of vitamin D is in our
diets when we ingest vitamin D it's
absorbed by the intestine the ones in
the blood screen blood stream vitamin
D's Bond vitamin D binding protein or
albumin and carry to the liver
there in the liver the vitamin D is
hydroxylated to the 25 hydroxine form of
vitamin D then the kidney
has produces another hydroxylation step
which produces the 125 dihydroxy vitamin
D which
which is the main
vitamin D
the major steroid that's involved in
Mineral homeostasis
vitamin D is involved in a very complex
hormonal control
when serum levels of calcium dip below
8.8 makes per DL it prompts the
proportional increase in the secretion
of the pth
pth signals the kidneys to increase the
production of 125 dihydroxy vitamin D by
increasing the production of 25 hydroxy
one alpha hydroxylase
the increase in the 125 hydroxy vitamin
D
stimulates the increase absorption of
calcium in the intestine and upregulates
the genes in the bone to stimulate bone
remodeling
an expert panel in 2010
was put together to to determine vitamin
D guidelines
they reported that patient values should
be a single total 25-hydroxy vitamin D
measurement in nanograms per ml
yes they should measure both vitamin D2
and vitamin D3 with equal molarity
serum would be the recommended sample
type for vitamin D testing
and we should also report health-based
reference intervals
in this quote Finney at all accurately
state that total vitamin D must include
the contribution of both vitamin D2 and
vitamin D3
to get the best result to assess the
patient's condition
either being deficient insufficient or
sufficient for vitamin D
these 25 experts divided the clinical
applications of vitamin D testing into
two groups
classical applications for which the
level of evidence is very high with
numerous randomized controlled studies
and then some of the non-classical
applications for which long-term studies
still need to be done
and they are being done but the amount
of evidence is increasing with with the
introduction of additional studies
so for the classical applications we
have individuals who are at risk or have
osteoporosis
elderly patients with a recent fall
pregnant women
patients with chronic kidney disease
transplant patients obese individuals
Etc
some of the non-classical clinical
applications are in the area of
Cardiology
autoimmunity
and oncology
so for years we've monitored vitamin D
to help determine our bone health in the
1930s bone health was improved
dramatically by fortifying milk products
with vitamin D
this is all but rid the USA of Ricketts
fortified milk is a major source of
dietary vitamin D in some countries
the use
of vitamin D is very important in
treating bone disease mostly
predominantly in osteoporosis in elderly
female patients
the numerous studies showing us this a
statistical link between vitamin D
deficiency and other diseases
these include cardiovascular disease
various cancers diabetes
glucose intolerance multiple sclerosis
and autoimmune disease
these statistical relationships
are the reason that many Physicians
believe that vitamin D is a good General
Health marker
and non-skeletal disorders the benefit
of vitamin D as a treatment is still
being explored
so there the consensus panel had made
has made recommendations for maintaining
Optimum vitamin D levels
25 hydroxy vitamin D should be less than
should be greater than 30 nanograms per
ml
for patients who are at risk for
skeletal malformalities cardiovascular
disease autoimmune disease and cancer
they've also determined that we should
supplement first and then test
individuals with little or little sun
exposure or dark skin
the interval the testing should happen
after the individuals have been
supplemented is approximately three
months
the upper level of safety for vitamin D
is 100 nanograms per ml
a maintenance dose of 800 IU's per ml
per day should be given and we should be
reporting the total 25 hydroxy vitamin D
no
so the endocrine Society has
come up with clinical practice
guidelines
for the evaluation treatment and the
prevention of vitamin D deficiency
so infants and children who are at risk
should be taking 400 IUS per day of
vitamin D
uh
pediatric patients should have a a dose
of 600 IUS per day
adults 600 IUS per day age 70 plus 800
and Pregnant and lactating women 600
I use a vitamin D per day
if they're not getting that from their
diet they should be supplemented
so let's look at some
variability among vitamin D assays that
are currently being used
here we have six immunoassays and one
hplc and an lcms spec
so The Deco survey scheme is a survey
scheme that five samples five unique
patient samples
or patient sample pools of serum are
distributed to
Laboratories
that are reporting vitamin D
measurements
and those measurements are then reported
back to dequas and then a a report is
given at the end of each quarter for the
performance of that particular
Laboratories
vitamin D results
and as you can see here the amino acids
so this graph represents the mean value
of amino acids a through six being used
all over the world in hundreds of
Laboratories
the hplc
is used in a in a handful of
Laboratories around the world and you
can see the mean value with the hplc as
well as the ID LCM aspect value
so this demonstrates the need for a
standardization for vitamin D testing
due to the variability of different
assay manufacturers and different idlcm
aspect Laboratories reporting vitamin D
measurements
this was from the January 2013 d-class
survey material
so there are several factors that
contribute to the variability among
different manufacturers in different
Laboratories
um the most prevalent or the most
predominant reason why vitamin D uh is
variable in measurements is the
historical lack of an International
Vitamin D standard
there is a nist material
that is a concentrated form of vitamin D
that can be spiked into human serum and
used as a standard
however that material may not be
communable between amino acids
releasing
releasing Vitamin D from the vitamin D
binding protein is is essentially
important
and different manufacturers especially
with immunoassays have different
releasing
agents to release the vitamin D from its
binding protein
and so you'll be getting less or more
released which which would cause
differences between manufacturers
results
also
it's very important that we detect with
equi molarity vitamin D2 and vitamin D3
the use of some polyclonal antibodies in
some amino acids do not detect D2 and D3
with equilarity
heterophilic antibodies are always a
problem for amino assays so if they're
represent blockers are not added to the
reagent formulations this will impact
vitamin D measurements as well
and
before a standardization program was
implemented each manufacturer had a
different way or a different method by
which they standardize their amino acids
it was not a common methodology on how
to standardize the vitamin D
measurements from one manufacturer to
another
yeah
so a little bit more about vitamin D and
how it's bound to The Binding protein
vitamin D is embedded in a hydrophobic
Groove in the vitamin D binding protein
two water molecules in that Groove eight
in The Binding of the 25 hydroxy vitamin
D and its metabolites in to The Binding
protein
the vitamin D binding protein binds
vitamin D3 with a greater Affinity
approximately five times greater
Affinity than the vitamin D2
and so therefore not only do you need a
monoclonal antibody that can detect
vitamin D2 and vitamin D3 equivality
a releasing method must be developed
that will release the vitamin D2 and
vitamin D through D3 from The Binding
protein with equal molarity as well
a little bit more about the releasing
reagents of vitamin D from its binding
protein
since it's very hydrophobic
and binds to The Binding protein very
well this can be very challenging for
some Ria methods and most LC Mass Spec
methods an extraction step using organic
solvents is used this precipitates the
protein within the sample releasing the
vitamin D to the organic layer
essentially releasing all the vitamin D
from the from its binding protein in the
sample
an automated immunoassay on the other
hand is not compatible with Organic
solvents therefore other methods must be
used to release the binding to release
vitamin D from its binding protein
and for immunoassays the releasing
agents and releasing
procedures that are done are all
proprietary to that manufacturer
so a little bit about the three epimer
of vitamin D3 the three epimer
of D3 is an optimal Optical isomer of 25
hydroxy vitamin D3 this Optical isomer
is of clinical interest because it can
cause interferences in some assays that
quantify 25 hydroxy vitamin D3
if IDLC Mass specs are not run properly
to be able to resolve the vitamin the
three Epi form of vitamin D from D3
you'll get an over quantitation of the
vitamin D3 in the sample thus causing an
overquantation of the total vitamin D
that's reported for the patient sample
the three epimer is not in Fair in in
very high concentrations in normal human
serum
but there are some disease states that
cause an overproduction of the three
epic form of vitamin D3
that's the optical isomer in the cartoon
so again the failure to separate the
three epimer can cause an overestimation
of the total vitamin D3 in the human
serum sample
um
overestimating by mass spec that do not
differentiate them as I said a few
minutes ago
so it's very important that we detect
both forms of a 25 hydroxy vitamin D
both D2 and E3
assays should recognize the antibodies
should be able to detect D2 and D3 with
equal molarity for best performance
and Under reporting vitamin D2 if the
antibodies do not cross-react 100 to
vitamin D2 or very close to 100 can
result in over supplementation
which vitamin D and cause potentially
cause vitamin D toxicity
so the vitamin D standardization program
or vdsp had a few primary objectives
the bdsp is a collaboration between the
NIH office of dietary supplements
nist
the CDC and gent University
it's to promote the standardization of
laboratory measurements of vitamin D
now how are they going to do this
first of all a an appropriate standard
must be commutable not only within
different aminoassays but also from
immunoassay to lcms spec
so with the ddsp
um what this what this group did was
they they obtained 50 unique serum
samples
and um
in order to be communable among
immunoassays so the first thing that
they had to do with these 50 samples is
determine by a reference measurement
procedure or rnp
the value the analytical value of total
25 hydroxy vitamin D2 and vitamin D3
um this rnp was developed by both the
nist and Gayton University at Deptford
in the teen Ponce lab
these 50 unique samples were measured at
both Laboratories at nest and at the
University of Ghent
these samples were made available to
manufacturers of vitamin D assays as
well as LCM aspect Laboratories
reporting vitamin D measurements these
50 samples were then to be used as a
standard
now these 50 samples ranged in
measurement of vitamin D from five
nanograms per ml to approximately 100
nanograms per ml
these individual samples
collectively would then be used to
standardize
a manufacturer's immunoassay or an LCM
aspect laboratory for vitamin D
measurement
there are two Publications listed here
that describe the vdsp program
so the vdsp is very important because
historically there's been a lack of
standardization across manufacturers and
different methods so the vitamin D
standardization program will include
will improve the harmonization
test results for vitamin D that is the
goal
so a couple of questions
about the vitamin D standardization
program
what's a standardized laboratory
measurement of 25 hydroxy vitamin D
one that is accurate and comparable to
the nist and gut and gent reference
measurement procedure over time location
and laboratory procedure
second question
what are the nist and Gent rnps
the two methods are aligned uh they're
they're IDLC Mass Spec systems and
extraction procedures that are aligned
and they are anchored to the nist srn
2972 which is a concentrated form of
vitamin D3 with a quantitative value
associated with it
these rmps are used to align gold
standard measurements to survey
materials so The Deco survey materials
and the cap survey materials are now
reporting bias to the rmp not to the all
method trend mean as previously done
foreign
so what is the uh the impact on clinical
assessment with respect to the vdsp
that this standardization will improve
the harmonization across manufacturers
and methodologies
that will also improve the confidence
that Physicians have and the accuracy of
test results
for vitamin D be it done on one
immunoassay or or a different
immunoassay the vitamin D levels should
be should be the same
this is just one example of a very
successful standardization program
the standardization National glycated
hemoglobin standardization program or
ngsp
or the measurement of hemoglobin A1c
in 1996 there were about seven Amino
amino acids on seven acids for uh in
global A1c
and the ngsp put out a survey material
one sample and that sample had
showed a very diverse
very different measurements with a very
high CV
so there was a need to standardize
hemoglobin A1c and over the years as you
can see even though the increase in
different methods
to measure hemoglobin A1c have been
introduced into the marketplace the
variation between measurements and even
within manufacturer has been greatly
reduced
so this is it's just one example of a
very successful standardization program
the CDC
has has implemented a
certification program for vitamin D
testing
so the CDC certification program it's a
two-phase approach
in Phase One
40 samples are made available to
manufacturers of vitamin D methods as
well as LCM aspect Laboratories
throughout the world
these 40 samples have values for the rnp
associated with them
they are used by the manufacturers to
determine whether or not their
immunoassay is standardized to the rmp
and if it's not then they can use these
40 samples in addition to the 50 samples
from the bdsp program
to standardize their methods
phase two is a monitoring program where
every quarter over one year
10 samples are sent blind to
participating Laboratories and
participating manufacturers
the test results on these samples are
then sent back to the CDC and a
measurement of bias and mean
CV
is determined by the CDC when they get
the testing results
each one of these phases as I said
consists of 10 samples they're tested by
the manufacturer in duplicate over two
days with a single lot of reagent
in order to be CDC certified the mean
overall bias needs to be less than five
percent from the target rmp value
and the mean CV must be less than 10 in
order to gain CDC certification
so the CDC is monitoring or has set up a
program to monitor
um the standardization of
vitamin D amino acids as well as LCM
aspect Laboratories
in conjunction with the vdsp program
something very similar that they've done
with estradiol and testosterone in the
past
so the goal here with the CDC
certification program is to improve
diagnosis and treatment and prevention
of diseases by standardizing Clinical
Laboratory measurements
so we'll create a measurement result
that are traceable to one accuracy bias
so a little bit about the Siemens
advocentar vitamin D total assay
the Siemens assay was introduced under a
standardization that we had performed
in-house
since the introduction of the Siemens
method the vitamin D standardization
program made available to us the 50
samples with rmp values
we have used those samples along with
other samples that we have obtained
that have rmp values associated with
them and we have re-standardized our
assay to the rmp
what this means is that we have an
internal set of gold standard materials
that we prepare in-house these materials
are value assigned directly from
the
90 samples that we obtained from both
the CDC as well as the the on vdsp
so our assay is standardized directly to
rmp standard materials
again we've modified the assay
standardization now the the assay itself
the reagents that are in the ready pack
the releasing reagent the antibody the
particles that are used in the assay
have not changed since the introduction
of the method
what has changed is the way that the
assay is calibrated
um
the calibrator values have changed
because standardization is now linked to
the rmp
so again essay standards are
manufactured
whose values are tied directly to the
rmp these standard materials are used to
Value assigned calibrator material as
well as control material and
MasterCard materials as well the mcns
this graph here demonstrates the Advia
Centaur method test results on the
y-axis
versus rnp values on 177 samples that
we've been able to obtain
the slope and intercept and the
regression coefficient are very good
so as you can see that the the assay
gives accurate test results to the rmp
from values of approximately five
nanograms per ml up to 100 nanograms per
ml that's the highest endogenous level
of vitamin D that we were able to obtain
with our MP values
so this demonstrates the alignment of
this particular Amino assay against the
rmp with 177 samples
as I mentioned before the
assay was introduced under a
standardization that we developed
internally
this is a
comparison of
the two different standardizations
for vitamin D the original
standardization and then also the
standardization to the rnp
on the y-axis and then on the x-axis we
have the dsorin liaison values
and as you can see the slope
with the
without rmp alignment is 1.02 and The
Intercept is negative 0.17 it agrees
fairly well with the DSO in liaison
the slope and intercept
once alignment has been done with the
rmp on these specimens is
0.93 and intercept of 1.22 so you can
see that the Centaur method
we only had to change the standard or
standardization and that's represented
here so
we changed our standardization
from our original standardization to now
the rnp alignment
this is a comparison of samples run on
the envious Centaur and then quantitated
with the two different standardizations
so the
current the
the original standardization is on the
x-axis and the vdsb standardization is
on the y-axis
and as you can see between about values
of 20 to 50 nanograms per ml
the values are very similar between the
different standardizations or as lower
than 20 nanograms per ml the values with
the rmp tend to be lower
and greater than 50 nanograms per ml the
values again tend to be lower
when referenced against the original
standardization for the method
this is a method comparison from France
against the diesel and liaison this is
um
the the rmp standardized method
for the Advia Centaur has been released
outside of the United States we are
awaiting FDA approval for the rnp
standardized method uh to be then
marketed within the United States
this is a
correlation between done in France
between the the liaison platform and the
rmp method and as you can see the the
slope is 0.92 and The Intercept is five
nanograms per ml this is very much in
alignment with the correlation I showed
you a few minutes ago between the r p
method and the uh diesel in the nasal
in addition it was a method comparison
done in the UK
this is the Advia centaur
um
original standardization on the x-axis
versus the rmp standardization of the
agony Centaur on the y-axis
and as you can see here the value is
less than 20 nanograms per ml read a
little bit lower on the rnp
standardization
um
versus the original standardization for
the method
this is the declass October 13th
distribution
in nanograms per ml again five samples
there's a sample 441 to 445 with six
different aminoassays the nist
um
now this is this shows what the rnp
value assignment of the material is
that's the the
um
the orange bar which is the third from
the left I'm sorry third from the right
for each sample
and you can see how it aligns with the
different amino acids
as well as the IDLC mass spec
so there is still some disagreement
between amino acid manufacturers because
not all manufacturers have been able to
standardize to bdsp if they choose to do
so
um the Siemens method we chose to
standardize to the vitamin D
standardization program
and our results are in good alignment
with
the nist value or the rmp value for
these five samples
so from
from January through October there have
been
several d-class surveys that have gone
out this slide represents the all
laboratory trimmed mean or altm
it also has the Siemens value
um
on the original standardization
we also show the Siemens value
once the assay has been aligned to the
rnp
the overall LC Mass Spec average for all
the results reported back to dequos
using lcms spec and I would like to
mention here that
even though a laboratory is running an
LC Mass Spec it does not mean that that
assay that that LC Mass Spec is linked
to the rnp
and all the turkey it's all determined
by what is being used as the internal
standard the quantitative value for that
internal standard
um different LC Mass Spec Laboratories
release Vitamin D from The Binding
protein using different organic solvents
they have different internal reference
materials ID LCM aspect
Laboratories can differ as much as amino
acids can differ it all depends upon how
the method is standardized be it LC Mass
Spec or immunoassay
but it's very important that we
standardize methods to Patient samples
the patient samples allow for the
communability between different amino
acids as well as to IDLC mass spec
College of American pathologist or cap
had a vitamin D
um
survey panel that they send out about
twice a year
it consists of three to five samples
here for 2013 there were two cap surveys
that were sent out
survey a and Survey B these are the test
and results from the final caps survey
and
um as you can see here the
um the target value is the rmp value
and we have different manufacturers of
immunoassays as well as idlcms spec
and the Siemens method here the Siemens
the Siemens values are from the rmp
all survey materials past the Siemens
method
the range is plus or minus 25 percent
that establishes the range that the
results Must Fall in to be cap
accredited for vitamin D testing
this is just graphically representing
those results
cap survey a of 2013
for the different manufacturers on the
previous page
these are the results from the abvd
panel B from 2013.
geographical
foreign
participated in the CDC vitamin D
standardization program as I mentioned
earlier I'm sorry certification program
as I mentioned as I mentioned a few
minutes ago these are the test results
from
the um
the four the four
sets of 10 samples that were sent to us
over the course of the last year
again the acceptance criteria is the
mean bias must be plus or minus five
percent
the mean and precision must be less than
10 percent
results are reported back to the CDC run
over two days in duplicate testing per
run two runs one run per day duplicate
measurements per run
and here we have the the Siemens return
value on the 40 samples as well as the
target value
for each one of the distributions that
were sent out the overall mean bias
was 0.3 percent and the mean CV was 5.5
percent the results reported back to the
CDC
this is the
correlation
presented graphically with the IDLC Mass
Spec rmp Target value
and the Machine is returned value
slope is 1.01 intercept of negative 0.42
and an R value of 0.95
so again this
is very similar to the 177 samples that
I presented earlier in the presentation
with rnp values compared to the Siemens
method
so in summary the publication of the
vdsp test results enables Laboratories
to know which manufacturers and
methodologies are considered certified
but using certified procedures
Centaur method has a mean bias of
0.3 percent and the overall mean
Precision of five and a half percent
the certification demonstrates that
Siemens is in alignment with the rnp
um
An approved rmp that was used for the
vdsp program
so in summary many factors influence the
measurement of vitamin D by amino acid
vitamin D binding proteins the three
ephemera vitamin D3
the ability of an amino acid to detect
increase molarity both D2 and D3 and of
course as a standardization
this standardization program the vdsp
along with the CDC certification program
will improve the harmonization across
manufacturers and different
methodologies providing confidence in
the accuracy and test results for
vitamin D
once again Siemens as we standardized
our method to be in alignment with the
gold standard
that's the end of my presentation
um I will
take some questions now bear with me and
I can
and I can read through some of them
this is a question
so this question
um
is what is your opinion or thoughts or
analytical challenges about the recently
introduced vitamin D assay
on a chemistry analyzer by diazine I
just saw this
um not too long ago and it uses a very
similar technology as an emit technology
um
I would
I have not tested this in my laboratory
yet
um
on a clinical chemistry analyzer
it's all going to come down to the
ability of the polyclonal antibody used
in that to equate molarity equimolar
measure vitamin D2 and D3
in addition
the emit technology does have
limitations on sensitivity
so I would be wondering how the the
analytical sensitivity was measured by
that immunoassay it does propose a
challenge running a homogeneous test for
for vitamin D but I've not used use that
method um
in my laboratory
um
I don't have any other questions at this
point in time please feel free to
answer any questions that you would like
well here's a question
this is by Miss Diaz from the Calgary
laboratory services
with the cost per test to be comparable
with msms technology
um
it's a good question I don't you know
you uh for an IDLC Mass Spec you have a
significant uh cost for the for the
instrumentation
since it's predominantly a lab developed
test where you need to develop the the
methodology used in your laboratory
using organic solvents and then of
course the liquid chromatography and the
mass spec
um
I don't we don't have an lcms spec
um I have one in our laboratory but um
I don't know how much it would cost to
uh
for an LCM aspect measurement
so it would probably be comparable to an
LC Mass Spec measurement once you
consider the cost of the uh the
equipment and also the highly trained
operator that would be required to run
an lcms spec a laboratory technician uh
Marina Centaur it's a completely fully
automated platform so that particular
immunoassay does not require the skill
level that that one would need in
operating an LCM aspect so depending
upon the
the the salary of the person running the
instrument the cost of the instrument
itself how many tests per day are being
run by that lcms back Laboratory
um LC Mass specs the throughput of an
lcms spec is quite
um
reduced compared to an ADB centaur
Centaur and other automated aminoassays
but Centaur specifically can turn around
about 240 tests on vitamin D per hour or
an lcms spec at best can do maybe one
result one LCM aspect can do maybe one
result
every five minutes
um I've heard as as fast as two to three
minutes
however the accuracy and the Precision
of that measurement being run so quickly
would be in question
and again when the columns are run
quickly the ability to resolve the three
epimer is in question
so you might be getting some
overestimation you if you're measuring
the three happy form of vitamin D
so you know at best you're looking at a
five minute per test result turnaround
whereas on on Centaur you have about 240
tests per hour so depending upon how
many how many tests are done in the
laboratory cost of the equipment etc etc
all those have to be taken into
consideration
foreign
I'll thank you for your time and um
have a nice conference